[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلال العشرين سنه المنصرم تقريبا حصل
عندنا تغيرات مناخيه لم تكن مكتوبه في
السجلات المناخيه المدونه او محفوظه في
ذاكره كبار السن المرويه جريان متتالي
لاوديه لا تجري الا على فترات متباعده مثل
وادي الرمه جراها السنه مرتين ربيع على
نجد تهامه والمعروف انه اذا ربع تهامه
اجدبت نجد والعكس صحيح والعامه يقولون
ياويل نجد من الربيع تهامه هطولات مطريه
غزيره في عز القير كما حصل على سليل
والافلاق وحوطه بني تميم وليلى في العام
المنصرم هذه لم تكن ملاحظه علينا بس بل
العالم لاحظة هذا الشيء فبحر العرب لا
يولد الاعاصير الا على فترات متباعده
وخلال هذه الفتره بدا يولد عصارين في نفس
السنه 65
اجفان اعصاري اما سئمت ارتحالا ايها ساري
بل اكتفيت واغناني السرى وشكى قلبي العناء
ولكن
تلك اقداري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعلماء حيال هذه التغيرات اقوال عده
اهمها من العلماء من قال ان هذه التغيرات
امور طبيعيه وهي تتبع نظام الدورات
المناخيه العظمى والتي مدتها 75 سنه فكلما
انتهى الدوره مناخيه عظمى منصرمه وبدات
دوره مناخيه عظمى جديده فان السماء تتمخض
الولاده هذه الفتره وهذا التمخر هو التغير
ومن العلماء من قال ان البشر هم اساس
البلاء بما احدثوه من ثوره صناعيه وما
ناتج عنها من ادخنه عملت على خلخله عناصر
المنظومه المناخيه ايضا ما فعلوه من
الاخلال في التوازن البيئي والحياه
الفطريه وهذا هو الذي سبب تغير ارضنا نقي
الفؤادك حيث شئت من الهوى ما الحب الا
للحبيب الاولي كم منزل في الارض يالفه
الفتى وحنينه ابدا لا
منزلي
[موسيقى]